les championnats de France de poney
commencent ce week-end à Lamotte-Beuvron
c'est l'ouverture d'un été placé sous le
site de l'équitation dans la commune qui
héberge le Centre Fédéral parmi les
chances de médailles tourangelle
victoire estivale 14 ans seulement elle
est engagée parmi les 60 meilleurs
cavaliers français Romain Delville l'a
rencontré aux écuries de la polynière
c'est près de Loches
c'est dans la difficulté et les bars
plus hautes que le duo que forme
victoire estivain 14 ans et son poney
Chivas 11 ans se révèle après leur
victoire au concours de saut d'obstacles
international de Pernay leur objectif
c'est le championnat de France ou
victoire est engagée en as deux
excellence c'est les 60 meilleurs
français donc là on y va dans un
objectif de pourquoi pas faire un
classement pourquoi pas
faire quelque chose de bien voilà après
là c'est vraiment les meilleurs donc
faut pas y aller avec trop de prétention
je pense mais de toute façon
peu importe le résultat qu'on phrase
sera une belle prise d'expérience pour
moi et surtout pour lui
c'est que l'équitation pour victoire est
une tradition familiale son papa la
coach ses grands frères récemment sont
aussi cavaliers mais cette année
victoire a franchi un palier en accord
avec son collège elle a accéléré sa
participation au concours de saut
d'obstacles à travers la France pour
s'aguerir gagner en confiance et en
performance je pense qu'il y a pas de
frein à sa progression là elle est déjà
un super niveau pour son âge pas oublier
qu'elle vient juste d'avoir 14 ans donc
je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de cavaliers
qui aimeraient en arriver là à son âge
là les championnats de France c'est un
objectif je pense qu'à l'avenir déjà
peut-être passer un petit peu plus à
cheval voilà ils ont déjà fait
l'acquisition d'une petite jument là en
fin d'année dernière engagée parmi les
meilleurs jeunes sur poney à partir de
samedi à Lamotte-Beuvron victoire
estivain se donne deux ans pour briller
à poney avant de s'engager dans la
catégorie cheval